okay Katie given the pay disparity
between workers and CEO hi you don't
take any breaks here we just should
should we have a maximum wage a minimum
wage end yeah that's been suggested
after you are certainly suggested it a
maximum wage yes a limit like you know
100 percent tax after if you make 10
million or whatever would know what I'm
asking somebody so I'm this is somebody
else's question and I think we should
have a maximum win I don't
Wow I think that what we should do is
have empowered people in this country
shareholders workers investors and we
should allow our capitalist economy to
actually check the wages of CEOs that
will work it has worked in this country
so should we have as a practical matter
a maximum wage our wages too high should
the guy at Pfizer have gotten that much
more money should Jamie Dimon beginning
paid to say he's think about it no but
to say there's gonna be some automatic
maximum wage or some perfect ratio
that's that's the recipe for messing
with what worked in capitalism for all
these years in the 1950s the top rate
was 70% would you support a top rate of
7% Oh on South it was higher than that I
think that's saying if you make a lot of
money what is your duty to contribute to
the collective good and and it's
substantial you should have the more you
make the more you should pay we should
all we are all in this tough progressive
except for in the last 40 years the
typical CEO pay was going up to 946 the
typical workers pay has gone up 12%
totally we totally need to change
something but the thing that we need to
change isn't some magical number some
artificial formula that we're gonna set
and what a CEO should be paid what we
need to do is have investor protection
rules have shareholders be empowered
have workers being getting paid a
reasonable wage compared to a CEO and
this is this is the recipe it's not some
formula that we're gonna just find
there's no perfectly proportional number
out there the biggest company in the
world we don't know what that's even
going to look like five years from now
okay I'm curious what do you think used
to be done to make sure holders more
powerful do you think they I mean this
is not a rhetorical question you think
they're in a poor position to manage
their aligning I get one of the problems
is that is that the vast majority of
Americans are not shareholders right so
every time Trump tweets about the stock
market right I mean he thinks it's a
joke but the stock market is falling and
so the reality is most Americans don't
have any retirement savings at all most
people are not invested in the stock
market and so we don't have the average
American having a say as an investor
because the average American isn't an
investor because they can't pay for
their apartment and they can't pay for
their health care and they can't pay for
their child care so for instance do you
think they should be able to take some
of the money they pay into say Social
Security can put into a private
retirement fund er no so how are we
going how do you want to encourage more
Americans to become shareholders because
I want to pay them do you think they're
gonna go invest in the stock market not
by bass boats have you met Americans the
world but it's very uneven 42 percent of
the people make minimum wage these are
the people I keep asking how do you live
they don't their lives are very hard
right look I'd like to see a wealth tax
because we've had a class war in this
country for 40 years and the overclass
has won and it's time for the rest of
the country to fight back
I have no problem with say we should
adjust the tax system and redistribute
wealth and get those who are earning the
most contributing the most back into the
system that has made them wealthy but
that's different than saying we should
have some kind of price cap on salary
okay
government currently headed by dr.
disruption to capitalism other is a
normal system of healthy system of
Taxation which we need to create in this
country okay and you need to start
treating earned income the same as under
and incomes so people who just sit on
their ass and collect dollars they are
taxed at a lower rate than people
actually go to work every day and Trump
said he was gonna no Trump was in the
campaign he was no Eric what what do you
think of Bernie Sanders 16 trillion
dollar climate change plan which would
mobilize society at a level not seen
since World War two I mean it's a it's a
huge amount of money but let's start
asking seriously how we're gonna pay for
the mess we're inheriting if we don't do
anything like a green new deal because
if we don't pay for a green new deal we
are toast we're where we are eviscerate
the conditions that make life possible
so so it's it sounds it sounds
outrageous but we need an emergency plan
because we are in a climate emergency
and if you're not seeing it in Brazil
this week I don't know what evidence is
going into my by the Amazon fund it's
we're putting the number on the screen
okay what can we expect from this
weekend's g7 summit great things
yeah exactly he's gonna be like yes Cody
yeah right cuz people there don't like
him you know is that I know what the
picture always people don't like him he
pouts right yeah you beyond Allah Merkel
I'll be Trump
[Laughter]
it's embarrassing it's not just
ridiculous and it's dangerous but it's
dangerous even everything that's going
shouldn't even go
they don't want them he doesn't want to
be there when I took the red-eye he left
tonight he left it like 20 minutes ago I
thought there was the red-eye wasn't
even gonna go when we came out here
tonight to start your show I was
convinced it would be better well that
he wouldn't even make the trip right
expressly cuz his spirit animal Putin
isn't there and that's you know his big
issues why isn't Putin here alright be
with somebody who loves you exactly yeah
you've got to think one reason we're
getting into this crazy trade war in
tariffs situation of today is cuz he
wants to go to the g7 meeting and flex
his muscles a little bit the guys he's
so insecure his ego is so fragile he
wants something to stand up on tonight
that's a crazy thing that he isn't a
handsome I think that President Xi can
out chicken him in this game because the
Chinese are not opening envelopes
looking at 401 KS she's job security is
a lot stronger than Trump's oh yes might
not be one of the 20 Democrats it might
be the Chinese president altum Utley who
brings him down read the all right by
the way he tweeted today our great
American companies are hereby ordered to
immediately start looking for an
alternative to China socialism what
would they have said if socialist Obama
and our great American companies are
ordered here by dear-bought Yeah right
like a drawer for the scroll you know
okay thank you very much everybody
[Applause]
you